joining us now entrepreneur and New York
Times bestselling author with his new
book the Thank You economy Gary
Vaynerchuk very good to have you on the
show these guys what is a thank you
economy you write about your success but
yeah dealing with this kind of
developing this concept you know the
word economy is a big word so I'm not
just throwing it out lightly I think
anybody who's living in the world in
2011 realizes things have changed you
know whether you're texting a trillion
times a day or you're using iPads or
you're watching TV with two other
devices and I think that in this new
word-of-mouth economy in the world of
Twitter and Tumblr and Facebook your
social equity
what's tumblr tumblr is world changing
very rapidly and the way we communicate
and the context of our relationships
based on these micro statements is
changing the way we vote is changing the
way we buy things you know if we have a
relationship and you say this orange
juice is delicious
I may look at that product differently
that's not something you would have
picked up the phone and called me about
10 years ago and so this economic impact
of the media infrastructure and the
context of that is huge he's got a great
personal story too you started working
in your father's liquor store right and
now you're like the the wine expert of
the world you got your own media company
what did you learn in your dad's liquor
store that you're applying now you know
I learned from an early story you know
guy comes in has a coupon that we just
sent out and said this is you know $4.99
I just bought this last week for $5.99
can I have a refund and the manager of
the time said no no you just have to buy
more at $4.99 and I remember being 16
looking up and saying that didn't feel
right and the guy leaves and I thought
he'd never come back he comes back a
month later and since I'm never shopping
here again to my dad and I just remember
thinking what would that look like today
that guy not only would be not coming
back to the store but he walk out and
tweet and Facebook status I mean it's
not just one person who doesn't shop in
the store anymore it's 10 and that's
something I'm passionate about so it
does this mean - thank you what kind of
music like this you go in and you buy
something it comes to see it's a food
coffee place sure 5:07 yeah and you're
looking for change yep and someone says
you know no fives okay you mean for the
seventh you're going to an Apple store
somewhere right away at the Apple store
can I help you you want to go back to
these places it's even further than that
guys there's so much data out there
right now how about this how about if we
have a great wine customer at Wine
Library calm and we know because we're
following that customer on Twitter that
he's a huge Jay Cutler fan we've watched
him talk about Jay Cutler for a month
and when he's buying wine at a rapid
pace and we're happy with him as a
customer we sent him a Jay Cutler signed
Jersey from eBay saying thanks for being
a customer there is so much more context
you know we always feel con you like
that right I promise you if somebody
sent me a Jets jersey eight years ago
I'm not shopping anywhere else and when
you get into the aisle and something's
19 cents less than what you buy normally
you may go for that now but if you have
a context of a relationship they help
you get your kid into nursery school
businesses are on the verge of being
humanized and it's coming so what you're
saying is not only are you being watched
from every angle and every little thing
that might happen in your store business
or website could end up being seen by
many more people than you to cope like
the guy who didn't get the buck back
from the coupon but that there's also
tremendous opportunity there's being
more small town to be more small town
rules to be more human you know I just
think what was very old as new again I
am literally believe this you know
social media scares everybody it's so
new and it's funny the DNA of our
grandparents I think is more in place to
be successful in social media today than
the people that are around it's funny
it's funny Andy Grove the the famous CEO
of Intel used to talk about this how you
know that with all this customization
and knowing stuff about your client
about your customers it really is like
going back to a small-town pharmacy
where will you walk in yeah guy behind
the counter says hey Mike you know I
look like I got this new thing in here I
know you're what you like and they can
make recommendations to you that they
actually know their customers in a way
that like Walmart or or Walgreens or
whatever doesn't necessarily know you
this social media allows you to do that
anybody who follows business knows it
goes up it goes down it goes up we just
have lived through the huge big-box
store era right
you walk in your not knowing it's all
price one-on-one marketing is here but
the Procter & Gamble's and the Nikes of
the world they're scared of this it's
not just slap three million dollars on a
Super Bowl ad this is putting your
dollars against humans and most people
don't think this is scalable I'm very
counterculture on this I think people do
scale so it's it's part of it as you
explain it is sort of this hunger for
socialization that's been missing for 10
or 15 years is more people move they
don't know who lives upstairs they don't
know who lives next door they get
divorced this hunger for socialization
on the street and know that Ricky just
graduated from high school and
congratulated their parents through
status updates now we know that this is
very interesting to me it's really turn
back the clock with gadgets and gizmos
and apps it's not scary to like if you
use you're running a restaurant sure so
I go on Zagat in New York there how many
thousand brochures I go to a certain
neighborhood I'm scanning through I
don't quite know exactly we want to go
you go through and you read the first
review worst dining experience in my
life that's a snap move I move on to the
next one well listen and then there's
things like Yelp and more importantly I
think this is God's of the world I'm
going to lose some of their power
because to me what's more important is
if somebody that I know when my social
graph says that if pants 96 says that
well I don't know that person they may
have a vendetta but if my uncle says
that and I can see that that starts
impact I do think and not what's you
know yoga's a got 2.0 there's a company
that's actually trying to do this trying
to do a surgeon it's a social search
engine right that's like that's gonna be
totally based on your on your social
grab my camera the woman from let me get
Flickr yeah well you mean hunch Caterina
fake yes can you think yeah they're
wonderful and Chris Dixon a partner but
let me tell you who's gonna be doing
this it's a small company called Google
and so when I don't think people
understand is that Google drop the bomb
the other day you know it's been SEO and
all this other stuff and I've always
been very down on that stuff it's gonna
be based on your social graph if I link
to a resort in Maui and you search
google for Maui resorts and you're
following me on Twitter you're going to
see that on the first page this is a
calm before the social media storm this
is mm all over again the internet came
out
it had a lot of hype the market crashed
people couldn't see returns and people
left it borders didn't believe in it
they gave Amazon the infrastructure
they're out of business Blockbuster
didn't believe in it they let Netflix
come in and put them out of business
social media has had a lot of hype the
last few years the next three are gonna
be soft because people are not gonna
figure out the ROI and then people gonna
be put out of business and huge
businesses are gonna blow up and explode
and take over it in 2013 14 15 Wow
yeah that's what's happening Wow maybe
this blew everyone's mind apart achill
on the travel recommendations that's all
I can say he'll get yourself so because
because if you give you particles been
to a resort someplace you want to go
down curious about something to say in
terms of the 2008 election and Obama's
use of social media which you say was
not so good is that
listen Brown great it was a starting
point but it's definitely not the
humanization of politics that I see you
know I know that if I'm running
somebody's campaign in two years or four
years in the social side that 100
percent they're gonna do a dramatically
more one-on-one engagement they're gonna
sit in front of Ustream for nine hours
and just answer questions Town Hall
style
scalable and real so it was a starting
point but it's not this great oh my god
this is the way it's always gonna be it
is a very early example of where things
are going okay we let him go yeah best
$20 bottle of Cabernet California right
now because he is on yeah you know I
would leave you in a different direction
I would say the left bank of Bordeaux
right now for 20 bucks is better value
than Napa all right there you go yeah we
need you to come back while Everett
doesn't come by the way often to give us
a sense of where things are going I was
that was that is Wow hi thank you I'm
yeah I love it
I'm in the trenches oh I've got it
online and all these sites that are
apparently replacing Twitter or not look
policing there's just so many more
things so many more great thank you
the book is the Thank You economy Gary
Vaynerchuk we appreciate